le président sadate a été assassiné le
monde en émoi l'échiquier du
proche-orient bouleversé madame monsieur
bonsoir
le président sadate est mort assassiné
un attentat perpétré semble-t-il par des
éléments de sa propre armée l'état
d'urgence vient d'être décrétée en
egypte par le vice président moubarak
qui a pris les rênes des élections
présidentielles auront lieu dans les 60
jours
il était une heure de l'après midi
aujourd'hui au caire midi à paris le
président égyptien assistait au caire à
une grande parade militaire
voici les premières images de
l'événement écoutez bien voici leçons de
la fusillade
il était donc midi de paris et 13 heures
heure du caire comme chaque année depuis
la fin de la guerre d'octobre 73 le
président sadate assister à un grand
défilé militaire
c'est le passage des avions au dessus de
la tribune officielle au sol il y a les
troupes et notamment d un géant des
engins antichars
vous entendez le commentaire du
journaliste de la télévision égyptienne
mais si la fusillade qui éclatent des
hommes se sont arrêtés juste face à la
tribune du président sadate et on
tentera de tirer d'abord une grenade et
ensuite des armes automatiques
zaugg se sont approchés de très très
près juste enfin diposition lâché le
rafale
découvrons la tribune officielle avec
déjà les premiers blés serez les
premiers morts c'est là que se trouvait
le président sadate dans cette tribune
avec tous les membres de son
gouvernement le chef d'état major et les
officiers supérieurs de son armée vous
le voyez une pagaille monstre sur cette
tribune avec des hommes blessés à terre
on commence à enlever les sièges où se
trouvaient toutes ces personnalités et
sousse et je siège le président sadate
et d'autres personnes blessées également
grièvement
ce sont donc six hommes qui ont tiré sur
la tribune officielle
ils sont descendus d'un camion militaire
ils ont d'abord lancé une grenade et
ensuite avec des armes automatiques qui
l'ont braqué directement sur la cabine
sur la sur la tribune officielle
ils ont donc abattu le président adam
des services de sécurité se précipitent
vers les blessés
certains seront évacués aussitôt et
notamment le président sadate par
hélicoptère vers l'un des hôpitaux des
hôpitaux du caire
vraisemblablement cet homme en grande
tenue de maréchal qui était allongé sur
le sol était le président saleh
non
quatre des hommes du commando ont été
abattus par les forces de sécurité
regardez bien nouveau les mêmes images
au ralenti ces images où on voit bien
les tireurs qui vise la tribune
officielle
et voici il s'approche de la tribune
voyez leurs pieds leurs jambes
le cameraman étaient couchés sur le sol
évidemment pour éviter lui aussi d'être
blessé par les tirs
là on voit très nettement les hommes du
commando courir vers la tribune
et en voici donc le résultat
alors sur le moment on a su donc que le
président égyptien était blessé que son
garde du corps ont été tués que
l'ambassadeur de belgique présents à la
tribune officielle était blessé aussi et
puis dans une pagaille indescriptible
que vous venez de voir le président
égyptien était évacué par hélicoptère
vers un hôpital du caire et tout l'après
midi nous avons vécu au rythme des
informations et des rumeurs le donnant
tantôt mort tantôt vivent maintenant la
nouvelle est acquise le président sadate
a succombé à l'hôpital pendant
l'intervention chirurgicale
même si aucune confirmation officielle
n'est encore venu du caire
alors nous avons en ligne notre
correspondant au caire pierre ses reins
hier quelle est l'atmosphère au caire en
ce moment même quand on a appris la
nouvelle de la ville pour mettre un peu
préfet jean pouvoir un peu leurs
sentiments
il faut dire que d'abord il s'est fait
la veille de la fête la grande fête
laïque et que personne n'était pas tout
à fait passé et puis quand le coran ses
billards planté sur la télévision tout
le monde a compris que c'était fini
alors je crois que j'ai bien plus
attention présidente a dû me rappelle
que j'ai posé la question de savoir qui
l'été dernier pour cette écurie t il m'a
répondu c'est dieu qui décidera de mon
honneur et pour l'instant je continue
mon entrée peux me vanter aujourd'hui
qu'il a vraiment accompli son oeuvre
parce qu'au fond il est mort ce 6
octobre 1981
ces derniers temps après l affaire
guerre d'octobre et surtout après avoir
fait la paix est ce que font les vrais
dacoury et la question maintenant pierre
est ce qu'il est acquis au caire que
c'est l'armée qui a perpétré cet
attentat la remise sur si les mairies
pour l'instant parce que effectivement
en attendant d'abord parce que les
peuples sont nés deux militaires donc
parce que c'est l'armée mais dans
l'armée vous savez il ya des éléments du
club et ce notamment au trio vendant la
paie des gens qui appartiennent qui sont
intégrés ce musulman
l'opposition était plutôt et celles qui
étaient en tout cas ça date était plutôt
les frères musulmans alors dans l'armée
ce n'est pas vraiment un peu détaché en
tout cas n'a pas réussi ils ont réussi à
abattre présent light peak mais s'ils
n'ont pas pris le pouvoir parce que je
vais vous le disais tout à l'heure je
ce pass intense sur les formes
constituent ils n'ont paru est ce qu'il
y à la foulée secousses en limousine
d'abord parce que tout le monde est
rentré chez soi nouvelles et pour savoir
qui va se passer
l'anniversaire de la guerre
finalement merci pierre serra oui anouar
el-sadate 62 ans chef de l'état égyptien
depuis onze ans c'était pour les
occidentaux
l'homme de la paix avec israël mais
c'était aussi pour une partie du monde
arabe et pour une opposition de plus en
plus coriaces en egypte même la bête
noire le personnage sa date bernard
benyamin anouar el sadate lançons armées
à travers le canal de suez les défenses
israéliennes s'effondre les égyptiens
ont réussi l'impossible le canal c'était
pour eux la main étrangère sur leur sol
en le reprenant ils ont retrouvé leur
dignité
du coup celui que l'on prenait pour un
homme de transition après la mort de
nasser devient un héros national mais
surtout ce prestige retrouvé cette semi
victoire allait rendre possible la paix
le processus commence donc le 19
novembre 1977
anouar el sadate engageant une
formidable partie de poker arrive à
jérusalem à ce moment là tout est
possible y compris le pire
on lui présente moshe dyan il pouvait
lui dire bonjour monsieur le ministre
mais c'est un shalom moche et que les
officiels disraeli entendent médusé il
rencontre gold amer et elle que l'on a
si souvent brûlé en effigie dans les
rues du caire
il lui baise la main dans des milliers
de foyers israéliens
on pleure le miracle s'est produit mais
c'est peut-être en se rendant à yad
vashem le mémorial aux martyrs juifs
qu'anouar el sadate abat une carte
déterminante à l'adresse du monde entier
pour la première fois un arabe fait le
lien entre l'holocauste nazi et la
nécessité de créer un état d'israël
plus que tous les discours c'est cette
visite qui va profondément marqué les
esprits en israël mais ce musulman pieux
qui porte au front les et bible la
petite callosités des bons croyants se
prosternant cinq fois par jour en
direction de la mecque n'oublie pas pour
autant son peuple n'oublie pas pour
autant la nation arabe
il se rend à la mosquée al aqsa de
jérusalem pour prier et quelques heures
plus tard
il va se faire le défenseur
intransigeant de la cause arabe
du haut de la tribune de la knesset
peine avalé la nuit ont capté pas à
baden et à massala médias et mais les
députés israéliens sont surpris par la
bouffée rue discours fumée anouar el
sadate va réussir à provoquer à forcer
leur admiration pour son courage il va
faire mieux qu'elle faisait plus tard au
four d'une scène extraordinaire qui se
déroule à la knesset avec madame golda
mais c'est un face à face étonnant entre
la grand-mère d'israël elle celui qui
vient d'avoir une petite fille 24 heures
auparavant je veux la paix de vie madame
gold amer et même une vieille femme
comme moi oui oui monsieur le président
vous m'avez souvent traitée de vieille
folle même une vieille femme comme moi
veut la paix je veux que nous vivions en
paix vaud et nous
visite à des affiches
ce pas alors permettez moi monsieur le
président permettez une grand-mère de
faire du grand caire c'est pour votre
question
et les ennuis vont commencer dès le
retour au caire d'anouar el sadate
même si ce jour là ils sont des milliers
dans les rues à acclamer le raïs cette
visite à jérusalem n'a pas fait que des
heureux
loin de là toute une frange de la classe
politique égyptienne craint que ce
rapprochement avec israël ne se fasse
sur le dos de la nation arabe en général
et des palestiniens en particulier les
longues tractations entre les deux pays
qui aboutiront finalement aux accords de
camp david vont les conforter dans leur
crainte c'est une paix séparée distille
le reste du monde arabe n'est pas
concerné les palestiniens sont oubliés
sadate nous a trahis voilà sans doute et
en l'absence de plus amples éléments
d'information sur l'attentât
d'aujourd'hui
voilà sans doute l'un des sentiments
clés qui ont pu pousser une partie de
l'armée égyptienne à abattre anouar el
sadate cette paix avec israël n'était
pas la leur dénoncé par l'ensemble des
pays arabes de la région
elle n'avait fait qu accroître
l'isolément de l'egypte la preuve
distille l'autonomie palestinienne sur
laquelle bute depuis trois ans toutes
les négociations entre les deux pays est
une utopie israël n'en veut pas la
deuxième cause probable à cet assassinat
c'est la montée de l'intégrisme
religieux en egypte et la répression
sans précédent qui s'ensuivit il ya tout
juste un mois plus de 15 cents personnes
--des est arrêté au caire des religieux
surtout mais aussi tous les opposants
qui critiquait anouar el sadate
c'est sans doute le dernier geste
politique du président égyptien
celui qui aura le plus irrité son armée
au point de lui coûter la vie en ce 6
octobre jour anniversaire de la guerre
du kippour
cette guerre décidée par anouar el
sadate pour redonner confiance à l'armée
égyptienne
anouar el sadate chefs d'état savez
mieux que quiconque qui étaient ses
ennemis et aussi leur acharnement à
l'atteindre mais c'était un homme têtu
et un homme pieux qui refusaient la
fatalité de l'attentât il ya trois ans
exactement 78 une équipe d'antenne de
rencontrer le président sadate
on lui pose la question croyez vous à un
attentat de vos adversaires arabes
écoutez sa réponse donne
jeunes ou il ne l'est il pas du tout
jackson cap c'est le temps du refus et
toutes ses dictatures tu ces régimes
dictatoriaux le voulait non seulement du
fait des agissements de la paix mais
aussi parce que nous sommes démocrates
ils ont peur démocratie qui pourrait
s'introduire chez eux donc je n'exclus
pas cette possibilité mais owen j'ai la
foi one person and hum hum valeron il
journée de ma vie avant que mon heure
mais ce n'est tout l'après-midi les
capitales du monde entier ont vécu au
rythme des nouvelles du caire ce soir
l'émotion est grande
d'abord d'abord bien sûr un jérusalem
sur place didier epelbaum optimiste
convaincu que le processus lui survivra
aux familles aisées reitman l'ex
ministre de la défense qui évoque ainsi
le président égyptien
on est convaincu lui aussi ses
dirigeants israéliens déploient des
trésors historiques pour approuver cette
certitude a une opinion stupéfiants
l'extrême droite est trop beau jeu de
réclamer l'arrêt du retrait du sinaï le
proche orient dit qu'elle n'est pas mûr
pour la paix surtout lorsqu elle repose
sur un savant demande venait de marquer
en quelques heures un retour à la
tension psychologique
prévenez avant la venue du raïs et ses
permanences qui est dans l'air qui comme
le dit très bien à leurs transistors et
aux émissions spéciales radio ces
canapés antisec massant la personnalité
ça s'était pas mise en doute
c'est aussi un artisan de mama lisation
à washington le département d'état a
refusé jusqu'à la dernière minute de
confirmer cet après-midi la mort du
président égyptien pour la politique
arabe du président reagan au moment où
le congrès compromet son rapprochement
avec l'arabie saoudite
c'est un coup très dur de washington à
la cances à paris le président
mitterrand a dressé deux messages ce
soir au caire le premier à madame sadate
je vous le lit j'apprends avec une
grande tristesse l'issue tragique de
l'attentât perpétré contre votre mari
cet acte de violence inacceptables me
révolte et m'indigne que mes entretiens
avec lui je conserve le souvenir d'un
homme rare est vrai qu'ils n'avaient en
vue que le sort de son peuple en
nom propre et au nom du peuple français
je m'incline devant sa mémoire
autre télégramme adressé par le
président mitterrand cette fois au
vice-président égyptien le monde perd
avec le président sadate l'un des
meilleurs des siens
autre réaction officielle à paris celle
du premier ministre pierre mauroy depuis
plus de dix ans le président sadate a
mené une politique à la fois sage et
courageuse qui avait conduit l'egypte
sur les chemins de la paix dans ce
combat et cette action le président
sadate savez qui les tirait sur sa
personne les oppositions les
ressentiments le n du fanatisme
ils le savaient ils en avaient à mesurer
le risque et avait décidé malgré tout de
poursuivre avec énergie dans la même
voie le président sadate restera aux
yeux du monde comme l'artisan tenace de
l'indépendance et de l'intégrité de son
prix la france entretenait avec lui des
relations étroites et cordiale qui se
sont traduits par un dialogue permanent
et mutuellement profitable à son
initiative la coopération franco
égyptienne a connu des développements
niveau
la france salue la mémoire d'un homme
qui a tout fait pour son pays et qui est
allée jusqu'à la limite de ses forces
pour assurer le bien-être
et la paix à son peuple le monde gardera
du président sadate le souvenir d'un
homme courageux et lucide
un autre message signaler celui que
valéry giscard d'estaing vient
d'adresser à madame ça date
j'étais bouleversée par la nouvelle dit
l'ancien président français le président
sadate était pour moi un ami fidèle et
un ami fidèle pour la france les
réactions bien sûr continuent d'affluer
de paris et du monde entier on ne peut
les citer toutes mes parts ou paul là on
se pose les mêmes questions et d'abord à
qui profite le crime
bien sûr l'un théorie la plus répandue
c'est encore et toujours celle du
colonel kadhafi puisque radio tripoli mm
à vue est allé jusqu'à annoncer
triomphalement les tyrans ont une fin
oui alors à qui profite le crime bien
qu'il faille encore je crois être très
prudent le matière le crime profite à
tous ceux dans le monde au proche orient
qui n'avaient pas intérêt si vous voulez
à ce que le rapprochement ce processus
de paix engagé il ya quelques années il
ya trois entre l'egypte et israël se
réalisent alors cela ils sont nombreux
on pense bien sûr libyen et vous
regardez en ce moment des images qui
nous sont parvenues il ya quelques
heures de libye de tripoli où des
manifestants des manifestations
spontanées entre guillemets ont eu lieu
à l'appel du colonel kadhafi pour
célébrer disons la mort du président
anouar el sadate
alors bien sûr à qui profite le crime 1
certains milieux extrémistes
palestiniens à des pays arabes du front
du refus
ils sont nombreux et on ne peut pas
exclure il ne faut pas l'oublier ou
écarté cette hypothèse en egypte même
depuis un angle de des farouches
opposants président sadate avait déclaré
au président sadate et dans la presse
qu'il n'était plus d'accord avec la
politique suivie mais par le chef de
l'état égyptien principalement sur les
camps des accords de camp david et sur
la lenteur de leurs applications
en tout cas c'est tout les chicken est
proche orient qui s'en trouve bouleversé
oui absolument c'est un bouleversement
total sur l'échiquier du proche orient
le président sadate était le seul chef
d'état arabe à avoir osé dialoguer
directement avec israël son voyage
jérusalem a constitué un coup de
tonnerre dans les rapports entre les
grandes puissances et l'egypte de sadate
est devenu en quelques mois le plus
fidèle allié des américains au proche
orient est je crois la pièce maîtresse
des états unis dans cette région sa mort
son assassinat risque de changer
radicalement les rapports de forces dans
la région
il est pratiquement évident acquis que
les durs du camp arabe vont se regrouper
et exiger une autre politique de la part
des grandes puissances notamment des
américains
est-ce qu'elle s'auto frappant c'est que
les modérés comme l'egypte ou l'arabie
saoudite ont ces derniers jours
plusieurs fois attiré l'attention du
monde sur les limites de sa que des
accords de camp david et sur le problème
palestinien
on peut pas encore dire ce soir que si
tout est à refaire aux chauriens en tout
cas la mort de cet homme courageux
extraordinairement courageux plonge
cette région est d'une certaine façon le
monde entier dans la plus profonde
consternation avec deux interrogations
que fera demain l'armée égyptienne et
surtout qui succédera au président
anouar el-sadate précisément paul avec
vous et avec toute la rédaction
d'antenne 2 je propose que nous nous
retrouvions à la fin de ce journal pour
une émission exceptionnelle entièrement
consacré à l'assassinât d'anouar el
sadate et à ses conséquences
nous remplacerons donc nos amis des
dossiers de l'écran mais nous gardons le
réalité puisque le thème de la soirée
était précisément la presse et ses
responsabilités un événement tragique
nous permet donc de le traiter un show
rendez vous tout à l'heure à 8h français
en france le dossier du jour est celui
qui fait en ce moment même l'objet des
débats de l'assemblée nationale il
s'agit de la politique énergétique de la
france pour les années à venir c'est à
dire l'évolution imprimé à toutes les
formes de l'énergie à commencer bien sûr
par l'énergie nucléaire
nous avons déjà eu l'occasion longuement
sur antenne 2 de vous expliquer les
données du débat pour fixer les idées ce
soir simplement une carte et des
chiffres jacques violet voilà la carte
des centrales nucléaires en service est
en construction dans le débat sur
l'énergie le gouvernement propose de
construire six réacteurs
mais il faut rappeler que ce même
gouvernement avait le 30 juillet dernier
annuler le site de plogoff et je les
cinq autres sites en pointillés sur
notre cas chose cat énorme pour les
tranches 3 et 4
le pèlerin civaux et golfech autre
tableau le bilan énergétique de la
france en 1981 en pourcentage par nrj
regardez le pétrole près de 50 % de
l'énergie consommée le nucléaire 10%
maintenant en rouge sur notre tableau
les consommations pour l'horizon 1990 ce
sont les fourchettes plus ou moins
en fonction des différents projets mais
aussi en fonction des croissances
économiques choisi de toute façon tout
le monde semble d'accord pour réduire le
pétrole et augmente et plus ou moins le
nucléaire le gouvernement engagera sa
responsabilité demain à l'assemblée pour
la première fois sur un tel aspect de sa
politique
l'issue du scrutin ne fait donc pas de
doute puisque la consigne de vote jouera
pour la majorité socialiste
une majorité pourtant bien divisés sur
la question du nucléaire
le premier ministre pierre mauroy s'est
rendu cet après midi devant le groupe
socialiste à l'assemblée
il a réussi à le convaincre de faire
bloc
patricia jean nolet tout s'est joué en
quelques heures aujourd'hui dans cet
immeuble de l'assemblée nationale il
fallait faire très vite pour trouver une
solution avant que le commence le débat
dans l'hémicycle à 16 heures face à face
le gouvernement et un grand nombre de
députés socialistes et dont hervé le
ministre de l'énergie chargée
d'expliquer la politique du gouvernement
arrive le premier suivi de très près par
paul quilès le chef de l'offensive qui
estime lui que le gouvernement va trop
loin sur deux points le nombre de
réacteurs nucléaires et l'extension de
l'usiné de retraitement de la hague
toute la matinée à huis clos ces sommes
vont donc défendre leur tête face aux
parlementaires réunis au troisième
sous-sol la position de peel s est
majoritaire au sein de groupe
la situation est donc bloquée le
déjeuner arrivent sont signés accord
comprenant on apprend seulement que les
députés veulent voter sur le programme
du gouvernement
évidemment si celui-ci minoritaire c'est
la craie après le déjeuner dans la tente
du premier ministre il ne reste plus
qu'à observer
visage et un des téléréseaux du vent
dans les voiles et plus une poignée de
main signe peut-être d'un prochain
accord entre paul quilès et le ministre
de la recherche jean pierre chevènement
en tout cas lorsque le premier ministre
arrivera on sait déjà qu'il ne veut
faire aucune concession
il n'y aura pas de négociation il ne
faudra qu'une demi-heure à pierre mauroy
pour convaincre
il expliquera que le programme nucléaire
est nécessaire pour l'emploi et pour la
relance
en ce qui concerne les sites des
réacteurs nucléaires il attendra l'avis
des régions concernées bref il ne cédera
rien sur l'essentiel du programme
le vote est donc favorable au
gouvernement 106 voix pour 43 contre
conclusion si la discussion est de règle
dans ce groupe soucier